après avoir été l'acteur préféré des
français en 2012
omar sy est devenu cette année à en
croire le journal du dimanche
le français préféré des français eh bien
figurez vous que le français préféré des
français a su garder les pieds sur terre
non seulement il a accepté de bon coeur
et quasiment son défraiement notre
invitation à se joindre à nous ce soir
mais en plus il a fait l'effort de venir
de loin avant pour venir à paris il lui
suffisait de traverser le périphérique
maintenant il lui faut traverser
l'atlantique
pourquoi omar est il devenu le français
préféré des français
et bien simplement parce qu'il est la
france oui omar où es-tu ici omar tuer
la france
vallonné et verdoyant boisé giboyeux
rocailleux est battu par les vents
tu es à la fois cultivée est en jachère
tu es le soleil de la riviera et l'ombre
glace et décors ont tué une friterie de
calais et un vendeur de ceinture au cap
d'agde tu regorge de richesses
naturelles de réserves inexploitées de
gaz de schiste qui ne demandent ma
tandis qu'à s'exprimer
tu es joyeux tu es marié tuer pour le
mariage joyeux
tu es une terre de contrastes sombre et
lumineux marc thuet la france
les hommes
là
non
enfin ce nom
alors
au fond motion
une preuve supplémentaire s'il en est
besoin s'il en était besoin que la
musique adoucit les moeurs bien